the cardinals trying to make it 15 wins
in a row and they're going to do that
behind john lester lester yesterday at
wrigley field honored for his 200th win
last time out and many of those wins
were wearing the chicago cubs uniform
they will go up against mr sampson yeah
this is the man that is charged with
shutting down this red-hot cardinal
lineup adrian sampson likes his sinker
and his change up he'll make some
sliders occasionally elevate a four
seamer and once in a while he'll cut his
fastball one and two with a 2.84 for
the guy they call yo adrian
he had a swing and a miss
i think that was a change up yeah yeah
two down no score just underway here's
tyler o'neill
in the air not hit that hard late start
hap sliding and ian makes the catch
and applause from the pitcher
sampson loving it he inhabit got a good
jump and with the feet first slide was
able to take a hit from tyler o'neill
john lester getting the start for the
saint louis cardinals
as he returns to wrigley field last time
out his 200th career win that was monday
at milwaukee now 77 of those 200 wins
were with the cubs the pitch to
contreras swinging a ground ball right
back to lester he knocks it down from
the first base side of the mound he
picks it up and underhands to first
conference is out leicester to
goldschmidt two away the switch hitter
ian happ
and got him to chase in a strikeout for
john lester
and the cubs go one two three
harrison bader went five for seven two
doubles a homer four runs scored and two
rbis yesterday
and bader
sends it out to right center
gone
harrison bader
one to nothing with an opposite field
homer
number 14.
that's lifted to left wisdom charging in
and patrick makes the catch and he will
lead it off when the cubs come up to hit
near the bottom of the second
one-nothing card
3-2 pitch
he got him took some off it and the
second strikeout for john lester two on
with one out for trace thompson and the
1-1
ground ball left side de young a turn
double play
6-4-3
on the double play
and we're through two
one-nothing st louis here comes the
one-two delivery
fastball strike three call
the young caught looking at a fastball
on the outside one to nothing in the
third inning and the batter now is tommy
edmond
very nice man as well yeah
ground ball to the right side scooped up
by alcantara he throws out throws out
tommy edmond it's a one two three inning
down to second goes al contra back to
the top of the order for wilson phone
ferris who has a chance to drive in the
tying run
that one lace to the base hit out into
left center and that's going to score
alcantara around third and in wilson
will cruise into second that rbi double
and the cubs have gotten even 1-1
lester will now face frank schwendell
two balls hand two strikes
by molina
somehow he holds on and it's a strikeout
number three for john lester what a play
by yachty oh he's gonna have a bruise
but he's got a strikeout in and out here
comes the 1-0 now to ian line drive base
hit left center the cubs are going to
take the lead vader is going to throw
toward the plate long high throw over
the head of molina all the way to the
backstop scoring on the play is
contreras
and down to second goes ian happ cubs
lead 2-1 and it is duffy at the plate
who's now four for seven in his career
against lester runners go 3-2 pitch and
a grounder de young up with it
and across the diamond and holding on
it's goldschmidt
they tied it then took the lead and in
the last 25 games 10 home runs 26 runs
batted in for tyler o'neil and the 01.
oh nail adds another
out to deep left number 11 in the month
of september
out of wrigley again
and we're tied 2-2
tyler o'neal with number 32.
wilson contrast batting with the bases
loaded
drilled up the middle that's a base hit
bodhi in alcantara around third he'll
stop
and the throw cut off by goldschmidt and
the cubs have to leave last time john
pitcher was in the washington nationals
uniform it was way back in may and the
cubs treated him rudely that day faces
still loaded for ian happ he drove in a
run with a single his last time
i want that bee working for me
ball four and a run in 4-2
the 1-1
and wisdom hits it softly to tommy
edmond
and the cubs have regained the lead
bodhi has scored one of the four cubs
runs
the strikeout for john lester catches
the corner number five today
undoubtedly this will be lester's final
ending he's approaching 100 pitches
today another 3-2 delivery alcantara
swinging a miss ends his day with a
strikeout and six this afternoon
samson rolling along sixth inning two
down nobody on
hop to the air center field trace
thompson
and how's that right there good work
six innings two runs adrian sampson and
the cubs have a lead schwendel has hit a
double in five straight games today a
line out to left a strikeout and a
pop-up
chases a ball off on a 2-0 molina
pounces on it and got him
yachty spinning and throwing what a play
wow the cardinals have runners at first
and third nobody out harrison bader will
back
benner banks heading to left arana will
score
lead is cut to four to three
three hit day
harrison boehner and newt barr i wonder
if he'll be bunning here
newt barr base hit
here comes johnny the game is tied four
four newt barr delivers
you can hear the new
and there's runners at first and third
nobody out and the young will bet
andy young
sends it out to center backing up making
the catch thompson vader will tag up
five four st louis here in the seventh
the mound is in the sun bounced sharply
toward the middle of the diamond glove
by alcantara and he throws out edwin to
end the unit
so the go-ahead run is now on base and
that's the one thing you didn't want the
one-two
miss he struck him out and the
all-important first out ortega is
grounded into three double plays and the
1-1
ground ball goldie to the plate bodhi is
hung up between home and third
the tag by oronato they get that out and
now maybe two
back to tommy edmond he'll throw to
third it's a rundown molina
boehner is in it
deyoung tags them out and they get out
of it
it's unbelievable
[Applause]
[Music]
right field hat back back some more
nice catch he's had a couple today
the 2-2 pitch
he got him but the ball gets away here
comes vader playing the point he is safe
he got the toe in i don't know how
here's the young
a drive
left center
yes
yes
deyoung goes deep and the cardinal fans
are going wild and redly
no cardinal team ever has won 15 in a
row this cardinal team is about to do
just that
ian happ checks in
half hits that one in the year center
field vader's going to turn and watch
that go look out in half with a bomb to
center field he got that good
his 24th and the cubs still alive and
again it comes down to their final
he strike him a cold third strike to end
it
for the first time in
129 years of st louis cardinals baseball
it's 15 consecutive wins it had never
been done before
until now